♪ (Canon de Pachelbel) ♪
- Située au pied du mont Royal
sur l'avenue des Pins, en plein
coeur du Golden Square Mile,
c'est cette propriété méconnue
à l'histoire extraordinaire qui
pourrait devenir la plus chère
jamais vendue au Québec.
- Welcome to this italian
Renaissance Palazzo...
- La courtière Liza Kaufman
décrit la maison bâtie en 1926
comme un palace italien
de la Renaissance.
- So, we're gonna start
with the high room....
- Et pour cause : les plafonds
ont été conçus par des artisans
venus d'Italie. Les foyers, qui
datent du 14e siècle, ont été
importés d'Italie, tout comme
les lustres. Et on retrouve
aussi ce banc, fabriqué à Sienne
pour nul autre que le pape.
- Queen Elizabeth II
slept in this room.
- La reine Élisabeth a quant
à elle dormi dans cette chambre,
laissée identique
depuis son passage.
La propriété a été construite
pour John McConnell,
un industriel montréalais qui a
fait fortune dans le sucre.
- Les propriétaires actuels
ont acheté la maison il y a
une vingtaine d'années.
Ils ont investi 20 millions $
pour la restaurer.
Mais comme leurs enfants
quitteront bientôt le nid
familial, le manoir de
32 000 pieds carrés comptant
67 pièces, dont 12 chambres
et huit salles de bain,
deviendra trop grand. Il est
en vente pour 29,9 millions $.
Trois acheteurs potentiels
se sont manifestés.
- Depuis 10 ans, les ventes
de maison de luxe ont quintuplé
au Québec. En 2010,
486 propriétés d'une valeur
de 1 million $ et plus ont été
vendues dans la province.
Le nombre de transactions
a augmenté chaque année
par la suite pour atteindre
2400 en 2020.
JOANIE FONTAINE, économiste,
JLR Solutions foncières
- Avec les prix qui montent
tranquillement, il y a de plus
en plus de propriétés qui vont
se classer dans le 1 million
et plus, et donc le nombre
de transactions à ces prix-là
va augmenter.
- Mais la pandémie a aussi eu un
impact. Le nombre de propriétés
de luxe vendues à l'extérieur du
Grand Montréal a bondi de 10 %
l'an dernier. Les plus fortunés
sont attirés eux aussi
par les arpents verts.
- On a vu un intérêt pour
les propriétés avec des grands
terrains, des bords de l'eau,
vraiment plus le secteur
villégiature qui a été
en forte demande cette année.
- Liza Kaufman croit qu'elle
n'aura pas de difficulté à
vendre la propriété de l'avenue
des Pins, un véritable joyau,
selon elle.
- Avis aux intéressés : les
offres sont toujours acceptées.
Ici Olivier Bachand,
Radio-Canada, M